à nos bêtises bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france à leur
première question qu'apporte ce délit de
provocation à l'identification qui
apparaît aujourd'hui dans le nouvel
article 24 durci les conditions de
l'exercice de l'article 24 mais on voit
bien que dans cette affaire aujourd'hui
à ce stade
disons c'est au sénat que se jouera le
destin de ceux de ce texte en
l'occurrence mais la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui l'exécutif c'est sur un
sujet où l'opinion publique est
finalement assez partagés c'est à dire
que quand on regarde les études
d'opinion dans la relation aujourd'hui
des françaises et des français à
l'opinion on se rend compte que malgré
un certain nombre d'affaires qui ont pu
défrayer médiatiquement la chronique le
soutien compte tenu du contexte qui
règne aujourd'hui en france aux forces
de police reste malgré tout très fort en
l'occurrence donc c'est ce qui renforce
décembre - la position aujourd'hui
politique de l'exécutif sur ce texte
malgré les manifestations qui
régulièrement viennent contester cet
article 24
alors on voit que cet article ne modifie
plus la loi du 29 juillet 1981 sur la
liberté de la presse mais le code pénal
un changement symbolique selon vous oui
parce que tout simplement on voyait bien
que le sujet essentiel qui cristallisait
un certain nombre de positions notamment
chez les professionnels des médias
s'étaient finalement cet article 24
quitté considérée comme une entrave au
travail des journalistes et au travail
de l'information donc il fallait de ce
point de vue là des mines et d'une
certaine façon le caractère hautement
inflammable pour la tourner partie de la
peau la profession de ceux de ce texte
donc c'est vraisemblablement ce qui a
motivé le législateur en l'occurrence de
modifier le contenu de cet article
justement est-ce que voilà ces
modifications l'assemblée nationale
finalement va va les garder
écouter aujourd'hui pour l'exécutif il
s'agit vraisemblablement aussi quand
même quelque part de sortir de cette
impasse dans laquelle ils se trouvent à
la fois où tenir une forme d' équilibre
entre la nécessité de permettre aux
forces de l'ordre parce qu'il ya une
demande quand même faut-il le souligner
des syndicats de police depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois pour que d'une
certaine façon la la la la la la
tranquillité des agents qui assurent
l'ordre public soit assuré notamment
tout ce qui les concerne personnellement
mais aussi leurs familles et en même
temps il faut tenir compte de l'émotion
qu'a pu susciter la rédaction de
l'article 24 dans sa première version
vis-à-vis notamment de la presse entre
autres donc l'exécutif a tout intérêt
est vraisembablement à ce stade à
trouver cet équilibre qui lui permettra
de sortir d'une situation quelque peu
complexe alors autre débat aussi qui est
attendue celle qui concerne le port
d'armes des policiers hors service ou
encore les compétences de la politique
municipale
à quoi peut-on s'attendre justement
est-ce que vous pensez que sur ce point
là aussi on aura un mouvement voilà
ce qui ne va pas dans le sens justement
cette fois coûté un sou 7 est très
difficile de le dire
ce qui est sûr c'est que la majorité et
est profondément aiguillonner à la fois
par encore une fois une opinion publique
qui manifestement sur la question de la
sécurité aujourd'hui fait de cet enjeu
un enjeu qui sera certainement l'un des
enjeux prioritaires lors de la prochaine
élection présidentielle et elle est
aiguillonné évidemment par une partie de
l'opposition notamment l'opposition de
droite qui considèrent très souvent que
les manuels macron et sa majorité sont
trop faibles sur les questions
régaliennes donc ce qui va
vraisemblablement déterminer aussi
disons-le à la position du gouvernement
de l'exécutif et de sa majorité
c'est la perspective des prochaines
échéances en l'occurrence c'est à dire
qu'il faut montrer que l'on reste ferme
sur cette question qui est une question
qui aujourd'hui dans l'agenda politique
est devenue une question prioritaire
merci beaucoup à arnaud gritti d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire